thank you so much to the fans this is
such an amazing honor taylor swift is
adding one more ama trophy to her
collection the pop singer took home the
award for best pop album for her ninth
studio album evermore swift was unable
to attend the awards this year but in a
special message to fans she sent all her
love and thanks the fact that you would
do this forevermore i've always been so
proud of this album evermore was one of
two surprise albums taylor dropped in
2020 the other a sister album folklore
i've always looked at evermore's sort of
folklore's adventurous fun younger
sister so thank you so much for doing
this the 31 year old singer also took a
moment to thank the swifties for their
loyalty in the release of her
re-recorded red album also just wanted
to say the fam thank you for all the
amazing support that you have thrown my
way with red my version it's been so
much fun i'm so lucky to be in your life
and to get to have you in mine the
re-recording of her 2012 album retitled
red taylor's version was released
november 12th and is already breaking
records and reaching the top of the
charts taylor's highly anticipated
re-release also came with the release of
a 10-minute short film of her
heart-wrenching breakup ballad all too
well starring dylan o'brien and sadie
sink
[Music]
[Music]
spoke with the songstress on the red
carpet at the film's premiere where she
opened up about why she decided to
revisit the record and how her fans have
inspired her to revisit her roots this
was something that started out as a
really hard thing i went through
the fans are the people who turned it
into something very empowering where
when they they were just saying to me
over and over again we want to listen to
your versions if you redo it that's what
we'll listen to so if they hadn't if
they hadn't done that i don't think i'd
be having this amazing
exciting experience of being here and
you're here and there's a short film of
one of my favorite songs i've ever
written and so that's all the fans doing
and so this is really i just wanted to
think about what could i do over the
course of one week that would make them
as happy
or try to make them as happy as they've
made me
you